[Music]
hi i'm sarah snook and i play shifts i'm
alan ruck and i play connor
we're gonna play together now who said
it who said it
time for a blood sacrifice that was pop
you think we're through not with the
shareholders
time for the blood sacrifice i give it
away
it was very nicely done i just said i
love you dad 10 times in a row i think
that doubles my lifetime count i'm i
vote for roman
when we did our little video tributes to
him what up pricklix it's me dr [ __ ]
and my dad hates all of you [ __ ]
bye-bye how was that was that good
what do you want this to be one wedding
and four [ __ ] funerals was it you at
your wedding no
i got nothing it's about that bear hug
letter starting the takeover
an acceleration
at my sister's wedding are you insane
it was kendall and stewie planning the
waste outtake over at sheep's wedding
what do you want this to be one wedding
and four [ __ ] funerals oh yeah yeah
nicely done
you whooped oh ass okay okay
all right who said if it is to be said
so
yeah greg the egg gregory hirsch
executive assistant to tom wamsgans
correct if it is to be said so it'd be
so it is
are you all right in episode nine in the
hearings it says 210 but it seems to me
it was nine oh no it's the beginning of
210 because it because he had done it
yeah yeah he showed yeah yeah yeah i
look at your face and no offense i see
dead babies
you do you say this no
yes it was me yeah
yeah not to kendall no no
you're good you're good keep going yeah
getting there i look at your face and no
offense i see dead babies
oh
um um gil yes yo yeah i mean i look at
your face and no offense but i see dead
babies
conor he's gonna be the next president
really i just wiped the floor with him
in a debate he was lucky that wasn't
televised
so i hereby convene the meeting of the
newly formed what the [ __ ] are we gonna
do committee i have no idea but i'll say
it again so i hereby convene the meeting
of the newly formed what the [ __ ] are we
gonna do committee it sounds like
nothing like jerry would say yeah
so i hereby convene the meeting of the
newly formed what the [ __ ] are we going
to do committee this is something to do
with the cruise scandal coming out i'm
going to say yes
i'm going to say yes to everything you
say
i'm a good guy
i'm better than you we'll [ __ ] beast
them
we'll go full
[ __ ] beast
[Music]
you